hello everybody and welcome back to cry
of fear okay
the sounds sound like there's someone
following me like they're the same so I
got you a bag
okay cellphone better batteries for
safety seconds hold up my shotgun ah
okay that was something something
terrifying anymore anymore wanna mess
with me you thought scary why can't I
just why do I have to can I do a wield
can I please oh oh man
not cool man not cool man definitely
sounds like something is trying to
follow me oh boy get out of me get out
of here bro bro get out of here oh man
dude man dog is that door flare
okay what oh all right
what the heck is that
where's that where's that good cat a
dead cat okay why was there a dead cat
okay it's following me following me oh
whatever it is it is following me
god no Matthew be bro
don't Maithili burro hi hi
pick up Claire hey kid I don't want it
anymore screen wouldn't lick her so much
around those flares just when they're on
the ground so it's not that
donar going on Oh dark oh I didn't need
to like that it was right there darn it
okay
now I asked why did I need to come down
here
good question
I keep looking over in my clock hoping
that the time has passed a bit more than
I think it has
I'll okay I'm tough on top Oh
all right where am I going
what am i doing quit and that's good
what okay down there
open up for me yeah don't tell me ah
nope not today
what you got pick me up at all
I'm getting rid of this that's his
annoying Oh got rid of it Oh Oh stupid
I'm terribly stupid guys apparently just
terribly terribly stupid
again you're following me I don't care
anymore
whoa spitting blade of death
oh hello hello okay going down there go
down in the hole I'll go up here
thankfully they're giving me enough
flares I don't know why they suddenly
started popping up but thank you to the
flares oh man
okay in another hole I got a gun don't
mess with me bros I'm out of ammo oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no a blind shoot
any woman lady delicate flower that
comes my way okay I can toss it
Oh reload Oh reload oh okay
all trains so gonna come through here oh
no oh good run run just run bro
just run run there we go
thank you for busting through that okay
I need another okay you just stopped god
it's like they don't care about my
safety
okay all right where am I now
oh I've just feel like I'm being led in
the maze just non-stop maze no end in
sight
cutscene
it's really hard to hear because there's
something going on in the background
that's not just oh it's the flare god I
hate those players okay once then I'll
call the doctor in a second yeah the
players just like unbelievably loud and
in your ear the entire time that's just
annoying not like the flare
so something up here why did I go this
way
I'll follow the doctor in a second
usually done okay there's no what's in
here anything
course
all right dr. hurcomb he didn't run away
Oh dr. feelgood Oh No
okay come on get through the gap really
really or can I just not go through
there I can't okay
three point point all right boss
one guy up you immediate cutscene I
didn't even do it it's key and a battery
lying on the ground I better take okay
why not
Renji battery
oh no you give me you give me that
battery I'm dropping the flare
no God no come that work yes oh thank
you finally off last night last night
what that that gave me a battery it just
gave me a battery it just is my phone
bug is he just bugged
okay there we go God all right
oh don't go up the down escalator what
am i stupid okay alright I'm gonna try
that locked door that I saw before you
know which one of them Oh bed guys don't
even try it
I bet you can't even follow me up this
stairs I'm not even gonna waste the ammo
aah
Oh run juice I hate that
bye-bye just get out okay so maybe nope
it was a salmon
Ronald Street key tag Ronald Street all
right
Ronald Street maybe here well I didn't
need the key I suppose but Lisa's way
out okay what we got here
well this doesn't look good
to the car Oh God
no no no get him out here and boom I
don't know why my phone bury my phone
flashlight didn't work for a second
there but yeah no one likes you didn't
scare me you guarding huh
what are you guarding whoa that guy's
big that guy is really big Oh what the
hell was that
oh okay head blows into your gun and you
reload anyway yeah ha ha ha
[ __ ] up that's all boom headshot gimme
that Oh so bro through the bus assault
rifle yeah don't even try it
yep didn't you dump okay cool
assault rifle mega super awesome get rid
of the flare because I don't care I
don't care about no flare if they want
me to use a flare again they get a well
first they get up well if they need me
to use the flares and they're gonna give
them to me okay
was that it
okay single shot burst fire I'm sticking
with single shot because you need to
conserve your ammo and all that jazz is
that it do I have to go back to face the
big tall guy probably hey no guy I don't
know if this guy can die which is the
problem that looks like a no okay what
the heck how do I get past that guy then
I'm bit well I'm willing to bet he insta
kills me because that seems to be the
general trend of things in this game you
see some enjoyment and menacing and
we'll probably one shot you what to hack
where do I go then Anson square
there was no other way right oh really
you fell down to staring at this key
must go somewhere I mean really I did
just waste a bunch of ammo on that guy
so that's kind of sad
Oh what the heck maybe that door
I won't budge crap it must have been out
there someone musta been maybe I'm going
the wrong way
I don't know well I haven't been lost in
a while so it's about time to do
maybe if I sprint past the big guy Brent
past him I'll be able to get through cuz
I was supposed to go down this way
I believe let's see if I can get past
him a run run you stupid goose Oh can't
run
okay he's like just all in the way I
don't see a way around him
hang on oh let me ponder this got a big
dude obviously I'm not gonna waste the
bullets to try to kill him and I already
did waste bullets try to kill him so
hmm his mystery has yet to be solved
good point yeah did I save here I don't
know if I did right now whatever let's
save again just in case that way if I
die from the big guy I can at least come
back alright alright let me try to get
around the big guy if I fail you can
watch me die spectacularly alright you
want some big guy oh what's that oh
you're not so tough
we'll go come ah I can what wait what's
going on Oh what the hell
Oh reload reload reload that guy was
just nothing really he was just there to
be intimidating really oh you're not
you're not just there to be intimidating
hello goodbye okay in another Park and
more crazies all over the place I'm no
better shot than that good shot gosh
like a boss and then reload where am I
going
okay those big guys aren't so tough go
can it right no it cannot there's
another shovel ah yeah here yeah here
okay I gotta cut it here but thank you
guys so much for watching we cut back
I'll still be probably being chased by
these guys so thanks again and I will
see you in the next part
markiplier no no not that I'm stupid
bye bye